The goal of the Arden Syntax
is to provide a standard approach to
describing medical logic so that it can
be shared across EMRs to support
Clinical Decision Support or CDS.
CDS is the idea that computers
can suggest optimal therapy
based on a patient's electronic record.
Or spot potential mistakes
before they happen.
To do either, they not only
need the electronic record,
they need to understand at least
a limited domain of medicine.
That's where Arden comes in.
Arden consists of medical logic modules,
or MLMs,
each supports one clinical decision.
Here's a group of five MLMs used to
provide clinical decision support for
the use of Warfarin, a common but
potentially dangerous blood thinner
often given to patients with strokes or
other potential blood clotting problems.
Too little of the drug
may mean another stroke.
Too much can cause excessive,
or even fatal, bleeding.
Warfarin levels can be effected by many
other drugs and even the patient's diet.
So it's a very tricky drug to manage.
A clinical test called PT/INR is used
to assess the degree of blood thinning.
You can see here that the modules,
once they are fed clinical data about
the patient, such as their PT/INR,
can make Warfarin dosage
recommendations to the physician.
I refer you to the text for
the internal details of the Ardent MLMs.